today on stick to football we have a
killer show for you Matt no and Connor
today we get the grade mellows Mock the
teacher gets taught the grater gets
graded I'm looking forward to ripping
apart baby brothers mock drill turning
into like a boxing announcer oh yeah I
need to work like Don King your hair's
done taller everybody gets a nickname
yeah I like it I like it we do have a
fun show though Darren's in Evans
running back from appstate Jordan love
bury the lead here quarterback from Utah
State so two awesome interviews at the
end of Melos mock draft today but I have
exciting news that I can finally
announce you've probably seen us hinting
at some changes coming to stick to
football and yeah it's happening stick
to football live stick to football
becoming a show we are basically
television stars gentlemen coming very
very soon yeah my agent please someone I
don't have one uh we should we will be
in live three times a week in the
Bleacher Report app I explained it to my
dad this way today our dad who's 70 I
was like it's basically like a TV show
on your phone pop that's the best way to
describe it which is probably just blew
his mind because he doesn't even know
you can watch things on his phone yeah
you know he probably has no idea what
YouTube is yeah it's gonna be awesome
obviously we've been you know prepping
for this for a while we didn't want to
release any news too early but for all
of you that like watching stick to
football on YouTube this is the premium
version of it now you'll get things like
graphics player highlights it's gonna be
a full-scale show with us three leading
the charge so I know we're really
excited for it there will be some
schedule changes so just bear with us if
you're used to just waking up and
pulling out turning up the old iPhone
there might be some times where you have
to wait a little bit but it's gonna be
well worth it
it is gonna be worth it we are very
excited we've been doing some tests
behind the scenes it's gonna be amazing
we have a great production team so yes
schedule change but three times a week
you open that'd be our app and you're
gonna get see us live not pre-recorded
all the mess ups even today when I
couldn't say stick to football they're
gonna be in the show before we get to
Melos MOC which I'm like
my hands together on YouTube already to
just tear this apart there is some news
there's a fight between Leigh Steinberg
and an anonymous NFL exec because the
former NFL exec has said that Tula is
hiding injuries air quotes if you're
watching us on YouTube Leigh Steinberg
comes out and says well actually
hashtag two doctors have cleared too uh
so gentlemen we've said I think we've
tried to toe the line on this show of
hey we're a little skeptical of some of
the information but then they went
through to a third party doctor and two
of got cleared I've always worried more
about how healthy is he in three years
or five years now how healthy is he
right now but I like the least time
Berg's pushed him back a little bit and
then it's Leigh Steinberg Dean Jackman
why I I still think it's a bunch of
he-said she-said stuff I don't know who
to trust and I think the teams are kind
of feeling the same way I wouldn't be
surprised if we see to have fall down
the draft boards I didn't do that in my
mock draft that's coming up but honestly
I wouldn't be surprised of teams like
the Dolphins and the Chargers just say I
have no idea what's going on with that
hip I'm not gonna touch it I'll take a
guy like Justin Herbert or maybe I'll
just wait till the second round and grab
a guy like a Jalen hurts
yeah I'm really curious to see how much
smoke there is here guys like what is
real what is not is there gonna be this
yet you know draft a slide for tua where
we're all sitting there and we're like
wow he really fell to the teens and
somebody's gonna roll the dice on him or
is this just all BS and somebody's gonna
trade up two three four to it that's
what I'm wondering
I think the ceiling is so high with tua
I'm gonna bet on the ladder that he's
gonna still go in the top six picks but
I think the build-up to this I don't
want to make you know fun drama out of a
guy's injury but I think it's definitely
created some significant buzz and they
complete staredown leading up to the
first night of the giraffe absolutely is
and you know it is lying season and
smokescreen season I had a one of the
top agents who's not least Steinberg
texts me today and he said I I think
that to a kid slide and this is a guy
who doesn't have one of the other
quarterbacks so he's not saying it to
get me to push his guy up but there I
think there's a lot of smoke out there
so the Dolphins are either doing a great
job of lying to everyone or this
information that's coming out is
credible and I
think that again this is what will
happen verse what should all of us have
to is our number two quarterback you
guys are a little bit higher on him that
I am but none of us think he should fall
in this draft but we're just it's our
job to tell you that this could be a
possibility based on what we're hearing
yeah I think so too and I think that it
is lying season which kind of leads us
into our next thing that we have here
we're seeing a lot of these pro days
come out and I don't know about you guys
but I don't know if I'm buying it grand
ultimate virtual pro day runs a 439
about 212 pounds and then a guy that I
really liked out of mississippi state
camp dancer he ran a four three eight I
don't know if I'm buying these pro day
times I don't know if the NFL is either
I am definitely not buying these pro day
times at all
I appreciate that agents are filming
them and like would grant out but they
did like that there are four different
angles grand album maybe ran at four
thirty nine I think he's more of like a
four or five guy but cam Dantzler ran a
four six four at the combine and I do
think he's faster than that he's not
four three eight if he runs at four
three eight
so do I there's no way that that man ran
some four three eight and I like cam
Dantzler like set Melo
I put almost zero stock in these proto
videos I'm coming up NFL is gonna have
the same thing I mean I there's so many
guys that you talked to her that you
know our scouts are used to be Scouts
they don't trust another colleagues time
me and you could both be sitting here
working for the 49ers right now a new
time you met four three eight night I
mean before for one and I'm not gonna
trust your time I'm gonna go with my
time yeah that's my official time and
that's what I'm gonna report so I don't
think they're gonna take the word of
some video I mean our buddy big country
we saw him we're at a video right with
it time time around being video the
whole time no one believed it I don't I
think the NFL is gonna fall into the
same boat yeah I just don't I'm not I'm
really not buying the cam dancer one
guys I mean you don't run in the four
sixes at the combine and then run a four
three eight at the pro like the whatever
we want to call these I guess we'll call
them pro day times that's just not how
this works I think would Delp it I do
think he's a good athlete for his size I
don't think he's a four three nine guy
but like Matt said
you know you add a little bit he looks
like a four four or five guy on film
that's great grant Delpit getting to the
spot is not the problem grant Delpit
making the tackle when he gets to the
spot is a problem but cam dancer though
yeah I think long speed is a question
and I know we go back to saying hey this
is the guy that you know held Jamar
chase in check that he did but I think
long speed at the next level is the big
question we cam dance learn he's just
not a 4:38 guy nope he is not you know
who is though Melo oh yeah big country
yeah that was a beer chug time for 300
no I I don't think I could do that
either small one give me one of those
lay it out you know what I'm just not
good at it I don't chug beer I can drink
a lot of it
I can't drink a lot of it quickly yeah
no can't do it all right Mel you are on
the clock though buddy this is your what
you think will happen mock draft trades
are allowed and I let me preface it with
this you guys have both done your mock
drafts already this week and we sit here
and we talk to each other three times a
week we text back and forth a lot of our
opinions are the same so this isn't
exactly how I think the draft is going
to work but I did want to throw out a
couple different scenarios I liked the
trades you guys did earlier this week
but I kind of wanted to put something
different out and see how it goes
starting here with number one and you
know what let's just roll into it number
two I think these are the two easiest
picks in the draft Joe burrow goes
number one to the Bengals chase young to
the Redskins I think we can move on
let's start here at number three where I
do have a trade happening and I wanted
to explore with the NFL draft here what
would it look like if the Dolphins did
trade up we already saw what would
happen if the Chargers traded up now
let's look at it with the Dolphins I
have the Dolphins getting picked number
five
giving up pick number five thirty nine
and seventy so that's a 1 a 2 and a 3 to
move up to the third pick with the
Detroit Lions where they are going to
take the often injured quarterback -
it's hung in viola here at number 3 I
like it I think if they only had to give
up 39 and 70 they should do backflips
because well you know that's about three
picks that's about what the Jets gave up
I think to move up to that spot so it's
not far off but I like it I think if -
is there
I I still don't think they have to do it
it's my only thing like the way the tea
leaves read right now you don't have to
trade up to get a quarterback unless
you're trading up to make sure no one
else does it
hmm yeah I'm a fan I think this is a
really good move it's one from Miami
where you know I think everybody's kind
of brought the leverage down where there
was a time where we sat here and go man
somebody might go to to to get to it
that's how panicked they might be and it
doesn't feel like that anymore so for
Miami you're not giving up a ton in the
spot but you are getting your
quarterback and we say it week after
week I feel with injuries I feel way
better about two is crow career than
Justin Herbert's so I like the move yeah
do you think that maybe the Dolphins
start to panic and start to come up to
get somebody but I don't think it is
gonna take very much with them only
moving up a couple spots number four the
New York Giants and you're talking about
tea leaves
there's I've already been linked Isaiah
Simmons the pick here at number four who
leaked they have been brewed they have
been sipped III think I think we
definitely see this pink happen I feel
good about it
I know like there's a little part of me
that thinks if it's Trista wharfs two
weeks from right now when the draft
kicks off if they take Trista wharfs
here I'm gonna throw my hands up and go
well there was like there was like a 5%
chance it was gonna be him over I say a
Simmons so not ruling it out but I do
think it's Simmons is the guy there's
also this part of me that can see them
taking Makai Becton like like Dave
kettlemans just like I took the biggest
baddest mf'er I could find right care
what anyone thinks and I will say this
sacrum Berkeley running behind Makai
Becton is a pretty wild thought so I'm
not gonna rule that one out either yeah
and I think with the Giants too it's
who's making that pick is it Dave
gentlemen does he have you know 60% say
and he's gonna go get his guy cuz we
know what his drafts look like or is it
gonna be your new coaching staff do they
get a say because then I do think Isaiah
Simmons could be the pick there but
it'll be interesting to see what they do
a lot of people reporting that it's
going to be Simmons so I roll with that
one number five overall this the spot
that the Giants traitor sorry the Lions
traded back to they still get their guy
in Jeff Okuda I think that would fits
very well
number six overall is where this gets
tricky because I don't want to take
Justin Herbert here and what would
happen if they don't so I have the
Chargers taking the number one tackle in
this class and Jedrek wills Oh baby I
think that they are comfortable enough
with Tyrod Taylor they're talking about
bringing in Cam Newton they're not
talking about moving up for tua so what
if they stay here and they say we're
good with quarterback for a year and if
all else fails maybe we get one in the
second we get a guy like a Jalen Hertz
who fits that mold of Tyrod Taylor cam
who's Tyrod Taylor hey what a mobile
quarterback go get a younger one don't
reach for a guy right here in Justin
Herbert because you feel like you need a
quarterback you can get one and you have
a marquee left tackle now to protect
that young quarterback you're in love
might be there at the top of the second
round
exactly I like that mellow yeah I'm a
big fan of this move I want to be very
clear I think for the Chargers you're
sitting here you got jumped virtua you
need another tackle really badly a you
get a great one and listen you know put
your money where your mouth is if you
haven't read it you note I done had a
great story on Tyrod Taylor this year
there are clearly people in that
organization that believe in him I think
there's a lot of good pieces in that
offense and we know how damn good that
defense looks on paper right now god
forbid the Chargers stay healthy this
would be one of the better teams sneekly
one of the better teams in football in
my eyes number seven the Carolina
Panthers I have them taking tristan
works too i think they could use an
upgrade on the offensive line and
tristan works is an offensive lineman he
might be a right tackle might be a left
tackle but he's a damn good offensive
lineman i think that this team can take
him and start to piece together things
for your offense help protect Christian
McCaffrey you want to get Teddy
Bridgewater standing upright keep
everyone away from that knee get the
second-best tackle on the class so I
agree they need to do this I just don't
think they will
I honestly think of the board broke this
way and you don't trade out they might
be the team that takes Derek Brown hmm
yeah if I feel that way as well I really
do I think this is the ideal move I
would take Tristan wharfs if I was the
Panthers here but I the buzz around
Brown right now is picked back up and
we've been doing it with the Cardinals
for a while and I know there
and bass is sick of it and I'm sorry
guys I really do believe in the Panthers
potentially not even giving them the
chance to take him because I think
they've added some pieces to the offense
in this offseason but now in the draft
they could definitely look to that
defense I agree and I did almost go with
Derrick brown and number seven overall
but if he falls to eight I think they
sweep him right off the board we get
Derrick brown here at number eight
number nine a little bit of a curveball
Jaguars are sitting here with a lot of
needs there's also a quarterback on the
board I have them taking Justin Herbert
I think they're gonna fall in love with
Blaine Gabbert 2.0 all over the wires
get their quarterback of the future God
that is like that is his rule like if
he's gonna cool if he doesn't hit that
so he is oh yeah so this is another one
I could see this happening I don't think
it will I
I actually believe Jax Aviles give me
whether these teams that after the draft
signs Cam Newton or Jameis Winston to be
a backup yeah I think so too
I think Jacksonville here a lot of
directions they can go at nine I don't
think it'll be quarterback I think you
have to keep an eye on the receivers I
think you have to keep an eye on how the
corners now obviously a CUDA should not
make it here but CJ Henderson this might
be his you know ceiling as a pick and
for Jacksonville there's just a lot of
different directions they can go but I
don't think it'll be a quarter here's
the Dave gentlemen or did Dave get my
gun
Dave Caldwell is so good at keeping
things close to his vest yes when the
year they took Blake bortles they hit
didn't even meet with them so anything
could happen and that's why I think well
yeah it worked out so well if there are
you know the Chargers take a quarterback
I think Jordan love could be in play
here at number nine for the Jaguars
number 10 and number 11 I'll lump those
two together because I think both these
teams will target a tackle I have the
Browns taking Makai Becton and the Jets
taking Andrew Thomas I just don't trust
this Browns front office and I hope they
prove me wrong cuz Andrew Berry's a
really nice guy like if they took grant
Delpit here I wouldn't be like I'm not
gonna be surprised right it just feels
like they're gonna outthink themselves I
hear me nod Jeremy chin right or Ezra
Cleveland's like oh we need a tackle his
last name is Cleveland what in he's an
athlete
I'm starting to feel like he's gonna go
way higher than I had him I'm starting
to feel like he's barely in my top
hundred but you're
he's probably gonna go to Boston I could
tell you right now I think I am I have
to be as low on him as anyone
I look around I just I don't know about
that
you see him in the what round second new
eye and I feel like that was over
drafting now I think I've seen him in
the first round but number 11 good
tackle like Andrew Thomas going to the
Jets Connor go ahead oh you know I we
talked about this pick since September I
love it
plug and play player in a year where
teams will not have time to get these
rookies ready good run blocker good pass
protector sure he's not nearly as
athletic as wills or wharfs that's okay
that's why you're picking at 11 not in
the top five so I love Andrew Thomas and
think this is just a smart safe pick I
like Andrew Thomas I I do have some
concerns about him he's my number three
tackles so of course I like him
my concerns I just don't know how good
he is in space like anything he's really
good a phone booth and maybe that'll be
fine for the Jets I do worry a little
bit about him in space and number 12
overall we'll lump these two together to
the Raiders it feels like they need a
receiver I'm going to have them take
Henry rugs first overall I know there's
a lot of buzz mat that you're reporting
CD Liam might be the pick here I think
when you get these guys in a room and
you're debating about it and you're
starting to panic you're going to take
the guy with the four to speed and
that's Henry rugs and then CD lamb comes
off the board at number 13 overall to
your San Francisco 49ers I would rather
have Jerry Judy I know I said on this
show that in this offense I think CD
lamb is a lot like Michael Thomas I just
I really do think that Kyle Shanahan and
I know where we have a little bit of a I
don't know what you would call it right
you guys have a beef it's not a beef
because it's one sided they don't like
me I'm so you call that I like him I
don't think he likes me
normal however I marry yeah right yeah
maybe we're married I just I feel like
receiver is a need but I would value
speed I think it is telling that our
good friend Chris Sims maybe Chris can
fix this for me
Chris Sims doesn't have Judy and his top
five receivers and Chris his best friend
actually they have a matching tattoo is
Kyle Shanahan so maybe that maybe
there's something to that I thought that
was interesting too
and I'm not saying that's another [ __ ]
man all right I think we should just
move on no I'm just kidding I'm not
saying Sims just picky backs off of of
Kyle but I just thought it was
interesting
Judi not being in his top five and to
each their own because plenty of top
guys bust where I won't say anyone's
crazy for any kind of tight these days
but I think it's interesting I just
wonder if they if they're are aligned on
how they view receivers and what Kyle is
looking for and I will say it over and
over again I think Henry rugs is the
first wide receiver taken in this draft
would not be surprised not at all
all right let's keep it moving along
then number 14 overall a lot of
different ways the Bucks could go here
I'm going to give them CJ Henderson
though I think they look at their depth
chart and they look at what they have to
stop in the NFC South you need a corner
and I think CJ Henderson falling pass
seems like the Jags they sweep him up
here and number 15 overall this is where
Jerry Judi comes off the board if he's
sitting there for the Broncos they're
gonna be sprinting this card they're
gonna email this card superfast
to Roger Goodell at his home I think
these two fit very well with these teams
I I do think they fit it just feels like
they've been a team the easiest
offensive tackle obviously you have the
the big four coming off the board
already right yep so I know Josh Jones
here at 14 I don't think they do now I
wouldn't panic when you you haven't
needed corner and the number two corners
on the board I might just go full chiefs
with the bucks and take Judy and be like
all right Evans Godwin Judy good luck
but the problem is I do think that Tom
Brady still needs help in pass Pro I
would give Jason Peters a call they
spent a lot of pics on D B's last year
now none of them are CJ Henderson so
let's make that clear I do wonder what
the strategy is here for Tampa is it
seems like they're kind of on the
outside looking in on a good run of
players and number 16 overall to finish
out our first half here
the Falcons they could go Kinlaw I still
think they need an edge rusher I'm gonna
have chase on just a little bit ahead of
them and that's why I have chase on
going here I like his fit in this
defense and you have to get after
quarterback Kinlaw can do it a member of
the secondary can help out with that
quite a bit but I think the Chaisson is
kind of being slep on because he's not
chase young but he's still pretty damn
good yeah and I'm still bitter that you
let Judy go to the Broncos and not the
Niners you guys know I love chase on I
think I'm the highest person among the
group on him he would fit there the only
thing is like they have Dante Fowler I
don't know how they see tag McKinley
who's been pretty inconsistent that
would be one of the biggest questions
for me is how do they plan to utilize
him if he's gonna be you know a
linebacker on first a second down at
rush on third I think there could be
some value I would think that someone
like Javon kianlawl might be the pick
here with Henderson off the board
yeah I'm really curious with this
Atlanta team we know dimitrov will
explore moving up and moving down I
wonder how many assets they can
consistently put into Dan Quinn's front
seven I mean we know how much money
they've invested there and now another
traffic here but I like the player a lot
so it's it's hard to really crush that
when you like the player Atlanta feels
like a team guys that we're gonna be
talking about on Giraffe night one way
or the other because I think they're
gonna jump out of this pick right yeah
that's actually a good point I could see
them do that as well or you know what
it's time to Metro if you could take
running back yeah I mean it wouldn't
surprise me I think some fans would be
pissed off with that but that's the way
the board could fall let's take a quick
break when we come back we'll finish out
the rest of the first round here on
stick to football we are back here on
stick to football we're gonna give you
the rest of this first round mock draft
we left off with the Dallas Cowboys at
17 and Javon Kinlaw is there I think
this is just too perfect of a fit
Cowboys take the big defensive linemen I
mean he didn't play for the Carolina
Panthers first it's all I think that
confuses me because that's where all
their linemen come from at this point I
like kianlawl here if he's available
this is a steal yeah I think so too I
mean bowling and China pulling the china
shop here a guy that just absolutely
wrecks people in front of him
and I think a pick that once again if
he's there this one makes them way too
much sense
number 18 overall the Miami Dolphins
they have to be more happy with you as a
fan base than you guys because I gave
them to a and I'll give them Josh Jones
the tackle here protect your quarterback
who's
often injured I think this might be a
little bit of a reach for some teams
right here with the dolphins I think
this is such a need that you can take a
guy like Josh Jones and kind of stashing
or play him and developing the tackle I
think the Dolphins need to take a tackle
at 18 and 26 so you're off to a good
start
yeah I mean big fan of this one I think
Miami is doing way better in your mock
Melo than they did forever with Matt and
I I like this pick I'm just trying to
keep all those Dolphins fans happy
number 19 the Las Vegas Raiders I'm
gonna go with a corner here but I'm
gonna go with a big program guy who's
very athletic and Trevon digs I think
that he's gonna fit that mold of what
they want in Las Vegas and it's a corner
it's a big position of need they get him
here with 19 overall yeah I said I like
this pick for them I think I think I had
this pick in mine that's what I was
gonna say so obviously I like it but
yeah he does fit what mike Mayock wants
to do with this position especially
after you you know at 12 overall they
get an alabama player in rugs now you
get an alabama player and digs it makes
sense to me I like where your head's at
here too I'm starting to think Diggs is
gonna go a lot earlier than we've had
him in mock drafts over the last year he
was somebody that kind of hovered in the
20s and then was in the second round now
it feels like he's just climbing
climbing because everybody values these
long athletic kind of corners now do I
have him this high personally no but
would it shock me if the Raiders took
someone like him AJ Terrell jaylen
Johnson thinks he's going there this
would not shock me at all yeah I think
there's a lot of potential there a
little bit of development needed to keep
him and teach him how to play corner a
little bit more but I like him a lot
he's rising up my board number 20
overall the Jaguars and 21 the Eagles
let's knock these out cuz I have two
receivers going here
Justin Jefferson to the Jags and T
Higgins to the Eagles I think the Eagles
really need that other receiver I don't
love T Higgins here but I also don't
know if they're in love with the corners
I have these two teams beau taking a
receiver what's funny is they could both
also take a linebacker so you could have
had Patrick Queen at Kenneth Murray go
here and it also would have made sense
I'm really starting to like Jeff
Senate 22 the Jags I think that is a
low-key need for them and he would be a
very good fit in that offense
plug-and-play
kind of player and I think if you're an
Eagles fan you got to be heartbroken
here because I think there's a big gap
between Jefferson and Hagen's in this
spot and you have to wonder I mean the
Eagles they can get a big bodied guy
like Higgins do they take a size speed
guy like Mims through hammer or Rhaegar
go higher than we think
I'm fascinating to see what happens with
the Eagles if Jacksonville beats them to
the spot to get just in Jefferson and
another team that needs a corner here
the Minnesota Vikings I have them taking
AJ Terrell I feel like that's a good fit
with the length that they're going to
one at corner his athletic ability
there's some really good tape of AJ
Terrell out there I know you can find
some some beat up tape on him too but I
like the corner here and then I'll go
ahead and give you pick 23 the New
England Patriots and 24 the Saints
they're taking two of our linebackers I
am the Patriots going with Kenneth
Murray first I think they're gonna like
the guy in the middle that's a little
bit bigger they can make all the tackles
that just screams Bella check to me and
then the Saints get that athletic guy
right there in Louisiana and Patrick
Queen yeah I mean I love this as a
closeted Patriots fan give them Kenneth
Murray that captain letter on his jersey
just transfer it to New England I think
Dante Hightower getting older you lose
Calvin Noi Murray can can be he's that
rock-solid mature high character leader
that they need and then with the Saints
since you don't go quarterback here I
think adding speed to that defense is
absolutely something they need to keep
keep up and keep ahead of the a of NFC
South yeah I mean let's start with the
Vikings here at 22 you need to replace
Xavier Rhodes and Tyrell is a guy that I
think you know once again a long corner
that can run he can do that the Patriots
what Kenneth Murray I mean he screams
they're kind of linebacker just the guy
that I do think his versatile a guy that
you're gonna tell him you know you're
gonna give him room to run and freedom
it just to roam out there and make plays
and when you look at the Saints at 24
Patrick Queens one of the best cover
linebackers I've seen in quite some time
I don't know if they have a player like
that so adding him to that defense that
front seven next to Demario Davis is
something to be really excited about
and next up the Vikings again they
really need a receiver but I think they
can hold off I know we've been mocking
receivers to them in the first round
they gave up a receiver for a reason I
think they're comfortable there I'm
gonna go with gross mottos here at
demons event I think they can really
pair him up with hunter you've got a
very good pairing of defensive linemen
here that can get after the quarterback
weight and get a receiver later we talk
about the depth here don't reach for one
in the first round just because it's a
position of need get yourself a guy that
can get after the quarterback get
yourself I like this one a lot you lose
ever sing Griffin you're bringing in
gross mottos I could see them go I mean
honestly if they don't go receiver here
they could go offensive tackle that
could go defensive tackle I like that
they go edge here I think that fits Mike
Zimmer philosophy really really well I'm
just worried about Kirk Cousins without
a ton of talent around him and what I
mean by that is you traded Stefon Diggs
is Adam Thielen it was a little banged
up last year is Adam Thielen enough in
this spot I know they kept the great
running game led by Gary Kubiak with
Dalvin cook some pieces on the offensive
line but when you look at it right here
with the Vikings I like eat or gross
Matos a lot I think this is a place that
he would thrive I'm just very curious
how Minnesota plays this wide receiver
draft yeah it would be interesting they
could I mean they could take a receiver
at 22 they could wait and take one later
a lot of picks to decide to look from
though the Dolphins up here
I haven't taken DeAndre Swift I think
that this fits too much and they need a
playmaker on that offense I don't like
any of the receivers here they take the
running back yeah I think they're set
for now receiver your hope is that
Devante Parker continues to be a
playmaker and they've got a good depth
behind him but I've had running back go
here a lot
I think the sleeper picked a watch for
is isaiah wilson from georgia at right
tackle though yeah wow that would be
interesting for them to solve not only
left tackle but right tackle in the
first round i'm also curious now what i
liked about this pick melo with swift is
i think he could play in any single i
think he could play in any scheme i
really do i don't know what Chan Gailey
wants to do in his return so that's a
big question right now as we look at the
Dolphins are they gonna sit there and
wait until day two to take a running
back and you know roll the dice that
some of the talents gone but of course
there's still players there or they
ain't going
one and say hey we're gonna get a guy
that scheme proof we can ask him to do a
ton of different things Swift from me at
26 is really good value III obviously
agree because me and you think the exact
same about Swift number 27 overall the
Seattle Seahawks and 28th overall the
Baltimore Ravens they're both going with
safeties here who maybe not the Xavier
McKinney as the grant outfits of the
world I have the Seahawks taking Jeremy
chin and I have the Ravens taking Kyle
Duggar the small school baby
badass safeties well and I mean your
ball special exactly but they're not
just safety so like Ravens Spanish
McQueary signed Chuck Clark well Kyle
Duggars not just a safety he's gonna
play all over in Jeremy chin I think we
said this on the Wednesday show that's
just kam chancellor but fast so walked
picks fit those teams philosophies
without a doubt it really does guys that
have so much versatility you know
bringing versatility to the table you
watch both play and you kind of wonder
are these guys linebackers while they
play safety that's what it feels like
for both of them for the Ravens to get
someone like Duggar that showed he can
cover tight ends and running backs
really well I think it's really exciting
I'm really fascinated to see what's what
happens with Jeremy chin there's been
first-round buzz for him all month I had
valued him guys as a end of round 2
player but it feels like he's gonna go
higher than that yeah I think that
safety is a need and a lot of teams are
gonna try to reach for a one but I don't
think it's gonna be McKinney I don't
think he's gonna be Delta that goes
first let's just stop us could you
imagine if I could go back in time and
tell you guys in July then we're gonna
have Jeremy chin and Kyle Duggar ahead
of Grant Delpit I would had to look them
up and July no I was I didn't watch any
of them last summer know and it was like
dope it is a top I mean he was like top
10 consensus player and then it was
McKinney after that yeah there were a
made it probably bit Brandon Jones
honestly would have been your third
safety at this in July Jordan fuller
from Ohio State probably even would be
not directed yeah there's a lot of them
not let's move along here the Tennessee
Titans are up a lot of needs here but
I'm gonna go with the defensive line it
screams my Crabill I think he wants to
get after the quarterback try to stop a
guy like Pat
mahomes but also have that versatility
to play inside to play outside stand up
put your hand in the dirt that old
Patriots mentality a JEP Anessa is a guy
we haven't been talking about a lot but
I think the Titans could be in a
position to take him at the end of the
first I would love this pick because I'm
still a huge AJ Evan SF fan and when you
trade draw KC I think you do have to
have a plan to replace him not that
epinasty you know plug-and-play
replacement there but with Jeffrey
Simmons on one side epinet on the other
you got a really really good defensive
line group I think we've officially
reached the territory guys where epinet
was overrated for so long but he's now
become underrated yes it's crazy to me
when you look at him he's a high floor
player he's a good run defender I do
think he can have eight sacks a year and
once again just the ability for him to
win leverage on the outside or inside
he's gonna be a very good run defender
so at 29 I know AJ Panetta epinet the
hot name to say anymore but when you
look at this Titans defense this is a
purple landing spot for a player that's
gonna start right away yeah and I feel
like epinasty like if he went 23 to the
Patriots be like that's good value like
that's a good pick for them Trey flowers
right yeah and like even it likes a
Kinloss out there and the Cowboys took
him a 17 yeah yeah kind of makes sense
be a good pick his range is all over the
place right now though alright in number
30 overall the Packers a lot of
different ways they could use this pick
but I do think it's gonna be receiver
I'm gonna give them Denzel Mims I like
the big target to go in this offense and
you look at the Packers and who they've
targeted at receiver it's all these big
guys I mean they like size that receiver
and I think Mims can give them that high
man yeah I think Mims is overrated now I
like him I think he's a top 50 player I
do feel like we're getting that height
weight speed bump from a guy who's
senior bull did not look like his
regular season let's just look all what
it is muslin not not even close I'm like
it is testing it's like goddamn look at
this guy test but remember last year
like DK Metcalf tested like if Superman
came to the combine outside of the three
cone and he went sixty fourth overall I
wonder if Mims is gonna be drafted a
little later than people expect right
now it
the point that we're gonna call it a
disappointment when it's really just
where he should have been picked all
along yeah I'm very curious as well I
remember I go back two months ago
probably like November I remember before
a show one day a midweek show I said to
Matt I said if you watched Mims and like
am I missing something because I had him
in the third round and you know we
talked about him a little bit and then
he goes to the Senior Bowl and he does
look like a top 40 kind of player he
goes to the combine he tests like a top
of round 1 athlete so then you have to
go back to the tape again and I just
think that he he doesn't play like the
athlete profile he has now he could
develop in and do that which is really
exciting and probably why he will be a
top 50 pick I do think guys 18 drops
over the last two seasons is probably
the biggest concern absolutely is and he
just doesn't play that strong but if
he's picked at 30 I won't be surprised
and number 31 overall the San Francisco
49ers I'm gonna give him Jeff Gladney I
feel like that secondary still needs
some help you can go after a corner
after you get your big-time receiver at
13 overall with CD lamp so Jeff Gladney
here the pick at 31 well you gave them
two tough em efforts in this draft class
I'll tell you that Gladney doesn't fit
the size profile that a lot of people
expect from a Niners corner with that
you know Seattle South tight defense
place plays it that's a he's so good
impressed coverage though you almost
ignore the fact that he's you know shade
over five foot ten I really like Gladney
whether you want to comp him to jaya
like Xander Trudeau vyas white I need
those late first round corners who
become very very good I think he'll be
another one yeah with gladdening he kind
of reminds me of what a healthy Jason
Barret could have been yeah I want to
see if that translates to the next level
and I know the Niners took a flyer on
Bray I mean man if Bret could have we
say this every year Bret could have
stayed healthy glad knees placed I was
very very similar to him and pic32
overall this is my favorite pick to make
in the entire draft because it is the
kids I said Chiefs but they're trading
this people they have to make a move
they have to get back so I have the
Indianapolis Colts coming up to take our
guy Jordan love at the end of the first
round pick 32 overall the Chiefs get a
third back and they only move to spec
two spots back to 34
think this is something that we're gonna
see if it's not the cold so it'll be
another team
the Chiefs need to move back another
team's gonna need to move up especially
if Jordan love's here yeah Jordan loves
their I mean that means that the saints
passed on him the Packers passed on him
and we're gonna talk to him in a little
bit about where he thinks he'll go but I
do think the Chiefs with only five
selections in this draft half the trade
back from 32 overall I did at this point
it doesn't sound like Chris Jones is
gonna get moved so I like what you've
done here for as Emmitt calls them the
Kansas City champion Chiefs yeah mellow
I like that you you thought with your
brain and didn't act with your heart in
this but it's hard not to take a player
to add to your team in these mock drafts
but this is the right move to do if
you're Kansas City you can get out of
this pick every single year if you want
at 32 because teams want to get their
guy before the stress and build-up of
day number two begins and you know t
that I think this year more than ever
guys we might actually see that with the
whole virtual draft trade scenario yep
and and re-signing bashad breelan which
they did Thursday afternoon means you
don't have to reach for a corner here if
you don't want to they're just running
back as Pat says all right we will run
it back mellow good mock draft I liked
that one we'll be back with Jordan Love
and Darrington Evans not together that
would be cool
separately right after this we are
joined today by one of the best
quarterbacks in the 2020 class devil a
query over the best arm the 2020 class
Utah state's Jordan love Jordan thank
you so much for taking time out of your
busy schedule to come talk to us today
man doing well now I want to ask
first things first men everyone when
whether it's us evaluating you or we
will talk to teams everyone looks at the
2018 and then the 2019 and they try to
rectify the difference between the two
you know how you looked amazing in 2018
Matt wells goes to Tech to Texas Tech
and then the statute off a little bit
this year how much was it was coach
wells leaving how much of an impact did
that have on your your last season here
yeah I mean it was a juice you know
impact for us you know having the whole
coaching staff know going to Texas Tech
and whatnot so know that impacted you
know our team a lot you know getting a
new coaching staff whatnot but no we had
coach Anderson coming back
you know use that Utah State before so
uh you know he's a familiar face he's a
great coach and made the transition a
lot smoother from that I feel like last
winter when wells left a lot of people
thought you might follow him to tech was
that ever something that you considered
oh no so they had a nose obviously you
know decision I had to make you know if
I wanted to go you know with them to
Texas Tech estate Utah State for me
knows it wasn't a hard decision for me I
knew I wanted to stay Utah State you
know boys they're you know I've been
working with for them rather than you
know just leaving with the coach so
Jordan what's it been like going from a
bit of an underrated guy then you have a
great 2018 season and then now the last
year
your name is talked about in the top 10
top 15 picks of the draft on whether
it's every draft coverage Show podcast
social media what's that transition been
like for you yeah it's been it's been
pretty cool to see just for me you know
obviously my family just to see you know
my name out there like that in the day
you know I know that's just it's just
all talk right now until you know the
draft happens and whatnot and we see
where I actually end up so but like I
said this is cool to see Jordan I was
watching the senior ball obviously we
were all done they're covering it and
I'm watching the game and Patrick
mahomes text and he was like who's this
number five with the headband throwing
the ball over the field and obviously he
knew who you were cuz Matt well you know
a tech now but how much of your game do
you watch my homes and think I have the
athleticism and the arm strength you do
a lot of those same things
oh yeah I mean he's a fun player to
watch you know I love watching him I'm
just you know seeing the crazy throws
you can make and different timeslots
you can get his arm into and just he's a
playmaker you know I love Washington you
know trying to take bits and pieces of
my game I mean from his game and just
add into my game because like I said
it's fun to watch so we're gonna see any
like left-handed throws or in under arm
behind the back any any of that [ __ ] I
believe that the hill
I'll do some some regular stuff there
any other quarterbacks out there that
you try to model your game after
obviously a lot of people have been
talking about Pat mahomes but what other
quarterbacks
would you say you kind of model your
game after oh man I mean I watch for me
like my whole life I've watched every
quarterback explained in a fellow
college I didn't love watching the
positioning and played to try and try
and take bits and pieces by me like I
said I loved watching
deshaun Watson as well Tom Brady Aaron
Rodgers no great quarterbacks that can
no I'm just playing make this commit
make plays and win games I was a little
Washington so what was your road like to
Utah State because we here you know
we're used to quarterbacks coming from
all over the place whether it was Josh
Allen from Wyoming obviously Pat from
Texas Tech not every great quarterback
comes from Clemson Alabama but how did
you end up at Utah State yeah so I'm in
high school you know I was a little
under recruited just based on my size I
was super skinny coming out high school
and didn't have the offers so they were
getting the Utah State offer and that's
my only be one offer so Wow
I was wrong I was wrong when Utah State
you know they took a chance on me so I
ended up there that's a lot like Josh
our story uh you know kid who just
bloomed late only offer was Wyoming and
it goes and like yourself you know has a
hell of a career I'm sure you're tired
of hearing the number seventeen when
people talk about your 2019 season it's
the 17 picks but your Junior your 2018
season 32 touch that's only six
interceptions I have my theories on what
was different between those two years
but like from your side of things what
went different those two years yeah
obviously you know the great year 2018
but uh coming in 2019 season you know we
had a lot of lying around whatnot but
for me know I've gotten some just
situations where I was trying to do too
much and make make plays out of nothing
really and force the ball downfield
fortunate I windows you know someone was
just relying on my arm a little bit too
much you know having a little confidence
thinking I can make every throw when I
couldn't in the sometimes you know
situations where we needed to play but
somebody had to go make play
no trust my receiver's stone up some
50/50 jump balls or whatnot and a little
bit too much so do you feel like that's
a lesson that it's better to learn in
college than it is to get in the NFL and
think I have this world-class arm
strength I can fit it into any window is
that something you've I talk to teams
about like height
I took my lumps in college and you're
never gonna you're not gonna become like
Teddy Bridgewater checking the ball that
every throw that's not your game but do
you feel like that that helps you in
some ways oh yeah definitely those
lessons I need to learn you know it
helped me know better learn it in
college then you know get the phone
don't 17 years so again but uh no way
I'll think about it you know seventeen
learner mistakes that you know I get a
learn from watched film and just can't
be letting those mistakes happen again
but yeah it's definitely good to learn I
think it's not without coincidence here
we've mentioned a couple quarterbacks
while talking to you Pat mahomes Josh
Allen where does your arm strength rank
when we're talking about those two guys
and yourself oh I wouldn't know you have
to have like a ton of them right now
I've seen the play to get Josh out onto
college and I've seen his honor he's got
a cannon so he definitely has a stronger
arm the meek for sure cuz I see us all
warming up and he was he was launched
there like 65 yards with ease and so but
uh yeah we had Jacob Eason on last week
do you have a stronger arm than him like
that besides of the combo but uh I
trying to give me the face it's been a
long couple months especially for you
guys that you know went to the Senior
Bowl you're talking to teams you go to
the combine you're talking to team's now
even though they can't come see you they
find a way whether it's FaceTime or
these zoom and Skype calls what is the
one question that you find most of these
teams asking you over and over again
Oh for me it's more about you know often
it's in how I can learn just
you know the author's rangu tossed a
note simple offense naughty plays no
huddle and they just want to see if I
can actually call players in the huddle
be able to learn you know a bigger
playbook and whatnot to make you know ID
calls you know make protection slides or
whatnot and see if I can handle that so
that's been the biggest question for me
you know it's kind of hard to evaluate
that and you know Skype interviews
whatnot so they kind of just give me a
place from their office to install plays
and see if I can handle that right now
so what do you been doing during your
quarantine or isolation whatever
whatever people are calling it that is
movie like the second month of it what
are you doing in your free time yeah my
free time playing a lot of video games
my free time for sure Madden Call of
Duty 2 games I'm playing there we go
twitch stream man you'd be making some
money while you're just sitting around
I've tried to play Call of Duty before
and I like games like Red Dead and I
play a little bit of Madden Call of Duty
makes me sick I actually feel nauseous
running around trying to do things like
that I just I can't do it it's not for
me I played right before it's too slow
for me part of our job here is not to
play video games but we do that anyway
but we have the predictions on where
guys like you are gonna be drafted so
what teams have you been talking to give
us a little inside scoop what teams can
we maybe put you with and when we do our
next mock draft oh I've been talked to a
lot of teams I mean about I'll talk to
dolphins Chargers Saints Packers I've
talked to I've talked to a lot of teams
so it's uh it's hard for me to try and
sit evaluate you know where I think I'm
gonna end up just go I'm talking to
teams and you know sometimes they might
not even need a quarterback so who knows
but uh they'll be interesting to see
what happens now I know you won't tell
us where you'd want to go and I
understand that but is there any kind of
preference you have whether it's warm
whether you want to be down south you
want to sit behind a guy like Aaron
Rodgers for years there any kind of
preference you have
oh man come Utah State I'm trying to I'm
trying to go to a place with warm
weather man yeah but now you see yeah
and you've mentioned a couple you know
the Packers the Saints there's some
legends on those teams that's something
you feel like would be beneficial to you
we've talked about my homes a lot at
people put that comp out there with you
a lot he got to sit behind Alex Smith
learn for a year and and he's really
credited his quick development to that
fact
is that something that you think we've
been official for you coming from you
know you're no disrespect to Utah State
but you're not coming out of the SEC you
know you didn't you didn't have Plagueis
LSU's corners in Alabama's corners is
sitting something could help you we did
a play I was gonna say he did have to
throw against LSU but no I definitely
think it'll be beneficial I mean you
know sitting behind a legend like that
and just be able to learn and just ask
questions and be able to learn her for a
year and however long that is the other
day you know it's my job you know I got
to be ready whenever I'm called upon so
we'll see happens and I apologize cuz
I've defended that LSU game a couple of
times so I should have known that I'm
just suffering here running my mouth you
know you can tell us that we're wrong
anytime you don't have to tell us well
right here you just very no I'm
definitely ready to take the field right
now I'll suit it up for the Dolphins and
I'm gonna be a Pro Bowler oh yeah I mean
that's the case I'll be ready yeah
especially that warm weather we were a
South Beach for the Superbowl you want
to go to the Dolphins I'm not I don't
know if it if you can somehow make that
happen that's where you want to be and I
don't know what your relationship status
is but you can get to Miami you will
definitely enjoy it I'm sure I'm sure
that LA is nice too though yeah all
right it's all nice Cali Florida will
see Jordan as you kind of get through
this process man how hard has it been to
just deal with the anxiety of not
knowing where you're gonna be next year
like for a lot of guys I mean even
coming out of high school like you said
you have one
one do you want to offer so you kind of
knew where you were gonna go now you
don't have a choice how hard is that
you know you'll know in three weeks but
to sit and wait to find out where you
can be playing yeah
I mean it's weird to just kind of sit
and be thinking like in two weeks I'll
be somewhere we'll see what happens with
the quarantine but just thinking like in
two weeks I could be somewhere that you
only know where I'm gonna go right now
so it's it's kind of weird but at the
same time it's you know some that I
can't control so for less than I've
always learned you know you control what
you can control
inside of my hands you know I've got to
be patient you know just wait and see
have you started to think about draft
day plans I know you can't pick where
you're gonna go and be drafted but what
that's gonna look like you know usually
we see guys like a status of yourself
you would be there for the first round
or you'd be with your family at home do
you kind of know what that's gonna look
like for you come draft day yeah I'm
gonna be at home farm be with my family
so we'll see we'll see how many people I
can actually have in my house be
interesting to see but yeah I'm gonna be
a home I'll be good I know they've been
asking players already especially
projected first rounders like yourself
if they can film the reactions live from
you know your home is that something you
would want to do or do you want it to be
a little bit more of a private reaction
now I definitely uh when I filmed and I
think it will be filmed but yes no
there's gonna be a special moment so you
know everybody can see that and sure
I'll tell you man Colts fans have been
screaming for you for like five months
we can't even take it anymore so if by
chance you end up in India I'm just
letting you know you're gonna have a
cult following as soon as your name is
called I'll be big yeah I've been in
contact with the coats - so I'll be I'd
be pretty huge see we got you all the
great spots to eat in India if you need
any recommendations should that happen
if it's the commando the combo well
gently to come by heard that uh what's
it called that steak lady crime scene
almost what was that Saint yes ain't no
st. elmo's oh yeah I heard that pretty
good it's good it's very good especially
if you like horseradish the the cocktail
sauce and the shrimp really really hot
really yeah I can't it sucks that you
guys go to Indy for like four or five
days you don't get to experience it's
just like stay in your hotel room go to
meetings go throw
don't combine different for you guys
though this year I know that you don't
have a combine to compare it to but
talking to your agent talking to the
teams that you did could you tell the
difference when you're interacting with
those guys no I couldn't tell any
difference you know I didn't really know
what the comm I was like before but I
guess only difference I knew it was like
the quarterbacks went first and the
groups and whatnot so but for me I mean
was a good time I had a good time out
there well Jordan thanks so much for
joining us man really appreciate your
time and we're excited to see where I
end up we really are we'll be rooting
for you yeah I appreciate you all right
thanks Jordan we'll talk to you soon
another great interview today on six
football you get to double-dip and we
have one of my favorite running backs in
the class actually highlight it I think
last week I highlighted this guy
Darington Evans from appstate one of the
fastest backs so if you're a like a
Chiefs fan like Melo a Niners fan like
me garrison you would fit perfectly with
either of our teams please please come
help our offenses
hey come get me I'll be down for it no
matter how many teams have you been
talking to because we I feel like you're
gonna be honest with us we talk to all
these players like I've talked to a
couple teams like how busy are you right
now talking to teams um I've actually
talked to a little bit more than half of
the league Wow it's kind of hard to you
know stay on top of it but you know my
agent they have a good schedule you know
we try to keep the schedule updated to
where I know which teams I'm talking to
on certain knees is there any team that
you feel like you have a really good
rapport with that maybe we can start
saying all right they're in tune Evans
probably gonna end up here on draft day
well it's kind of hard because um
obviously even at the at the combine on
my drive start really I would say
throughout the week talking the teams in
the interviews um you know a lot of
teams said because if I could be a coach
by the way I was talking and describing
off and you know explaining and talking
football of them so I've kind of been
getting the same vibe from every team
I've talked to I actually got a chance
to go out and visit with the Titans
before the corona stuff um but then like
the rest of my vids
you know kind of got turned into you
know face times or skypes and stuff like
that so I'm not sure it's kind of art
yeah it's been a crazy process for you
obviously Daniel Jeremiah has been
talking you up for a long time being an
app state guy then you go and you just
completely light up the combine and now
your names everywhere it feels like
you're not gonna you're not gonna make
it you know past the second or third
round what is this process been like for
you I would say it's been really good um
you know guys like Daniel you know back
in me I mean it means a lot you know um
you know a lot of people they this was
just you know I shouldn't go second or
third around just because I didn't go to
a bigger school but you know guys like
Danny who actually know football pay
attention to it actually took the time
study on myself and other guys you know
it shows on you know even even talking
obtaining they ask me all the time how
is unit a better school like out and I'm
lying it was kind of a similar situation
to now to where you know certain college
teams asking our which teams off with
you which teams were looking at you and
you know three four years later they
wish to man I wish I had this kid but
they just didn't want to take that
chance
man how you guys you guys win a lot it's
like disrespectful to say like how do
you end up at appstate when you have
teammates that are gonna be drafted with
you and you win a lot does that feel a
little like disrespectful at all I mean
yeah but at the same time you know they
don't understand the culture you know
that's that's on them they didn't take
the time to educate themselves on it
there's no need to even stress about it
that's a good point
Jared's in how good did it feel to run
that four-for-one III and I know some
teams had you like four three eight so
were you disappointed at 4:41 or were
you pretty damn happy when that time
flash on the bottom of the TV oh yeah
I'm not gonna be completely honest I was
kind of disappointed um you know I came
in with the mindset run a 4-3 out of
fact I met her running back room you
know um got the second-fastest time
which is you know was good and all it's
the Blessed lighting a higher standard
than when I ran that's a pretty damn
high standard what's the highest oh
what's the fastest forty time you've
ever
the fascism when I was required was a
436 yeah that's flying that's flying
have you been able to train during this
weird time where you know a lot of us
are quarantine but some players we talk
to you nothing has changed for them they
go to a private gym or you know they're
keeping their distance and some other
players we talk to you haven't been able
to do a lot what's your schedule been
like yeah I'm working out at a private
gym with a couple of guys from down in
my hometown all relatives and you know
old high school teammates we're actually
you know we kind of kind of stick to
ourselves work out as a group the worm
can push each other and hold each other
accountable knowing you know after we go
lift at the gym in the afternoon we'll
go run and then you know the I'll be our
date and then just come back and do it
the next day one of my favorite things
about you not just an athlete but you're
a guy who was National Honor Society in
high school and like you said earlier
team's talking to you love the
intelligence that comes to the table is
that something that you try to stress
when you're talking to teams is that you
are a guy that can understand the
playbook you're not gonna have any any
troubles you really hop in you know pick
up pass protection understand routes the
year you're really a do it all back yeah
I feel like um it's not really something
I have to stress I just feel like I can
have a conversation with them I kind of
understand that um you know just we're
not describe sometimes if I'm talking
offense we're talking I'm not just gonna
talk talk about it on the surface I'm
gonna go into detail so I make sure you
know I know what I'm talking about
versus you asking all right so what
about this like I'm answer your next
question before you basket so give us
you sound like a pretty smart guy Matt's
talking about it give us something that
we don't know about you what are you
doing in your spare time other than
working out preparing for the draft what
are you doing to keep yourself busy I
would say as of now on my reading
reading books on you know just helping
around the house with my grandmother my
mom and then you know from time to time
I'll pick up my Rubik's Cube a little
bit but I ain't picked it up in about
two weeks so I got it I got to get back
on it can you finish it and do it oh
yeah yeah it's a funny store
how I got into it so like in high school
Inbal senior class guys you know after
our season was over home we were in one
of our classes and there's like a half
semester class and one of the swimmers
at my school we get do it in like 40
seconds so we all were like all right we
wanted to turn this into a competition
so we all went involved when the next
day and we all right first first thing
we own guess the Rubik's Cube salt gets
a dinner on everybody else so it's about
seven of us so that's a free dinner for
every day of the week ended up ended up
getting it done finished in about two
days and then since then really just
pick it up every now and then whatever I
see one how quick can you do it
uh about say the fastest I've done it is
a low under a minute oh my god
yeah with me having touching one I think
the last time I touch one I actually
picked one up at the combine a song one
that the one of the squeeze I picked it
up and everyone's like you do not know
how to do that and I picked it up when I
did it like whoa if you don't want how
easy was the Wonderlic test for you then
I mean it was pretty straight it's
pretty straightforward you know went to
that you know it's just it's time you
know a lot of people you know don't
really know how to handle time and his
answer question I would say the best
part is you know even if it's a question
that you know you can answer if it's
don't take too long I'd rather just get
back go to waterside I'll take too long
to answer and then come back to it at
then I said you give me crazy questions
at the combine for many teams sometimes
you hear reports of you know them asking
weird questions like if you were a box
of cereal what would you be did you get
anything like that I think any questions
like that I knew not to mess with you
like this guy's the smartest one in the
room we don't need to pick his brain too
much yeah my dad again I wish I would
have maybe we can come up with some on a
show and ask you some Darrington are
there any pro running backs that you've
been watching to kind of build your game
around or you just kind of doing your
own thing I would say definitely more
recently on with in the past
years rocking moster you know he's from
my hometown he's got like a big brother
to me
Oh you know really watching him come
from Pop Warner high school to college
I'm switching between running back or
receiver going back and forth with that
and then you know getting to the NFL
would definitely you know some good to
seeing gave me a lot of motivation with
my process but guys outside of him I
would say definitely McCaffrey with him
going over a thousand yards receiving
and thousand dollars rest of that that
stood out in me
well I got some wife see my still trying
to do one day on Kamara Aaron jealous
guys like that
now you mentioned you know catching the
ball how important that is whether it's
Raheem or McCaffrey Kamara is that some
teams we've talked to you about because
you're not the biggest guy I think
there's a knock on your game it's that
you're not that you know you're not 225
you're a little bit over 200 pounds is
that something you've ever thought about
maybe playing more slot receiver or just
kind of being an offensive weapon that
can do a little bit everything yeah I
would say really just offensive weapon
type thing that's kind of what I've been
doing it out you know I came in that um
sinus athlete where she ran around the
back I was in both meeting rooms my
whole career I practiced that both
position my whole career but you know
people look at the stat sheet on paper
and they see on my Richards sophomore
year I had basically 1200 yards but what
they don't know is I didn't start until
halfway through the season on once David
Moore went down he's now with the Jets
and then I played my true freshman year
but even Jamie Moore once started my
true freshman he was behind Marcus
clucks
was all-time leading rusher so you know
my career stats are a little bit skewed
towards you know you know people would
say oh he didn't do much as freshman
year as research sophomore year and then
they like only have one year but they
don't understand the situation uh you
know what I was doing I was playing
receiver and around the back just to get
on the field um that was that's
something that coach said always wanted
I'm I knew that coming out of high
school like you know we got guys but you
know who wants you we want to bring you
in we want to get you on the third as
quick as possible so you know coming in
playing my true freshman year I some I
took pride in um you know I did kickoff
return I actually got to kick off the
turn record
right now you know just little things
like that yeah I'm looking at your
production right now as you bring it up
you you had a really good year your
sophomore year your junior year - with
18 rushing touchdowns 23 total I know
you didn't get on the field as a running
back but damn look at these kick return
numbers you got I've returned for a
touchdown
every year at appstate yeah it's wild
because really um much refreshing here
you know I got a little bit of case when
people stopped taking it to me and then
coming back Penn State was the first
team the kick it to me enough game one
of the season I took that a hundred
yards - touchdown after that don't
really want to kick and they're fast and
I didn't this passes and I would say it
was the worst as it gets I didn't get no
kicks um and then the one kickoff the
turn I had was on the onside kick
because no one really kicked it deep
they'd always either kick it to the off
returner or try and kick it out well the
good thing is your quarterback can just
turn around and hand you the ball they
can't prevent that happening I would say
so
yeah they can't do that exactly the
great job of that is so I go ahead
Connor Connor yeah we've seen you know
you bring up somebody like Raheem and
we've seen him just we've seen him
thriving a lot of different looks
whether it's outside zone whether it's
gap is there a certain scheme that
either teams are talking to talking to
you about putting you in or is there a
certain scheme that you really like and
feel you could thrive in yeah I would
say a lot of kids they're talking my
home you know getting me inside that
zone scheme similar I would 49ers do
except their backs
you know it's kind of something that
most angel slowly turning into get into
and then luckily for me that's something
I've ran my four years it out so you ran
inside I only ran outside I only rented
to perfection so he knows something I'm
used to something I've been running so I
know how to run it he knows just
learning the terminology of what you
know wherever I land whatever they do
and then just pick it up and running
with it now I pulled up my notes father
sitting to talk to you one of my
favorite things that you were actually
more productive between the tackles then
you were outside and I think a lot of
people see like here's this you know
scatback who's 200 pounds he can't run
between the tackles but you were most
productive running between the guards
which is surprising to me
what is that just vish
is that instincts is that your speed
what makes you a good runner between the
guards because that's pretty uncommon
for a smaller guy I would say it's a
little bit of everything I'm you know
coming off of my software talking to
jailer more you know he is he's already
with the Jetson stuff and he was like
you know one area I want to see you
improve on this year is running between
the tackles because a lot of teams doing
you as you know just a home run guy you
know give him the ball he might take it
70 80 yards but they don't see as if you
can do more than that when we can't he's
like I know you this is the year that I
want you to put in a play you know I'm
saying offseason work on that so you
know going into this past season that's
that's one thing I focus on key running
between the attackers showing people I
can run between the stoppers get 20
first touches the game five meter I'm
you know just doing doing everything but
I would say it it's a little bit of a
mix of using my speed my vision for sure
and then my elusiveness you know I can
under type it back to where I can slow
play it to a whole kind of tempo it and
as soon as I get there hit at 100 miles
per hour or I can get through 100 miles
per hour see a safety coming down you
know either out running you know create
a bad angle for him where stuff over on
a dime and make a good cut and they keep
eating north there's little things like
that I'm just kind of gauging my speed
it's so much like a pitcher does with
like a fastball and the change-up I
definitely see that when I watch your
game is there any team that you I know
you'd be happy any 30 or two of the
team's take you but is there any team or
region that you're really wanting to get
to you feel like fits you best
I wouldn't say there's any team on
particularly when they get to but I know
you know the way the 49ers run their
offense with outside and inside zones
game just any team that runs it's all
scheme that's something I feel I can
definitely showcase my talents and for
sure
um but any really any office that tried
to get they played at the ball in space
that's that's just I'm not going on the
last one for me cuz I always wonder how
you know we've talked to a lot of
players from quote-unquote smaller
schools I always like to ask them their
road to that school as they're gonna be
talked about as a top 75 pick top 50
pick what
your road like to appstate how did you
end up going there so really coming out
of high school you know I was the lowest
rated recruit on sign it out and my
shining class a lot of people don't know
that and I talked to school as I was
choosing the throne was the top three
hugging my top three was South Florida
State and then Bowling Green and you
know I was really high on Bowling Green
at one point then coach Beiber's ended
up going to Syracuse so it kind of
turned into a low-key wanna go to
Syracuse but the thing is you know with
we're one of our coaches on coach to
hold on he recruit in my area in Volusia
County he's a South Florida and often in
my junior year um and that state already
offered me money a year so really I was
talking to them a lot coach dijo ended
up going to appstate my senior year it's
where it's kind of like a double
positive you know and then I was just
committed that ended up being the last
two weeks of official visits I was going
to go to a state and then try and make
one up to Syracuse on the last weekend
then we got supposed to go to a state it
just happen to be a snowstorm that we're
you know I couldn't go that weekend then
we had to push it back one week so I
need I'm not even taking my fish in
Syracuse and then from there you know it
was all she wrote everything worked out
perfectly
I'm a four-time some fell champion
four-time confidence um well two-time
caucus game MVP four-time bowl game
champion stuff like that so you know
worked out in my favor I'm blessed and I
appreciate you know Cossack and Cruz
taking chance for me oh man we
appreciate your time good luck with this
process two weeks to go before the draft
kicks off to try to enjoy it and we'll
be rooting for you again like I said a
Niners fan here so hopefully you're
almost sure to be sharing a backfield
very very soon dude we appreciate a good
luck all right thank you